hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so this is my last video
on amc guys before i go to france so i'm
moving in three days i'm gonna arrive
there in one week
so i'm not gonna be able to do any
updates during the weekend because i'm
gonna be moving
so let's analyze everything that we had
this week already i'm only gonna miss
one session and let's see what the price
action is telling us let's get into it
[Music]
oh right guys so this is the situation
as usual guys i start on the daily time
frame to show you that we are in a huge
triangle when i use the logarithmic
scale which i believe is the right one
to use here because it's giving me very
good reactions
as you can see here i sometimes need to
move my trend lines but each time i
found a neutron line it's a trend line
that
has strong that is a strong resistance
because of the multiple reactions that
we have here as you can see so here here
and here so this is the level to break
it's 44. right now what happened guys we
had one very buried day yesterday we're
gonna discuss it i like what i'm seeing
here i'm gonna tell you what it means to
me
first thing yes so we were trading above
the moving averages as you can see guys
uh the day before yesterday so on the
23rd of november and we got civilly
hammered to be very honest with you i
was one of the buyers that got trapped
in there i bought around 41 something
like this
because i was hoping we finally break
out on the upside but it got delayed so
what can we do we wait
uh the next day what happened so we we
closed below the moving averages as you
can see here so that's why this was
unfortunately not a very good sign but
it is what it is and the day after we
started so on wednesday
we opened the session uh
lower and we went close to the
support area so basically we have some
support when you are wondering where are
the supports check always the previous
low it is the first support so here the
previous low was 37.5 and this is where
we had support we have more support just
below around 36 37 on this blue trend
line so we started the day bearish and
we found some support at 37.5 and we
closed the day
uh very close to the opening level
slightly lower than yesterday's close so
this is a red candle but even being a
red candle it is still a hammer so what
is a hammer a hammer is a candle that
has a hammer shape exactly like this all
right a hammer and it means that a lot
of cellars have been
hanged here just the same way when you
have those long patels here this one is
not very long but whenever you have some
long tails
this is a doji candle it's a reversal
candle too here you see for example this
is a shooting star so it's like the
hammer but the bearish version and the
hammer is here it can be red or green
it's strong if it's green this one is
red but it means that a lot of sellers
have been trapped in this move because
they were selling during the day and we
closed higher so not higher than
yesterday but higher than the lows and
we have this long tail so this is a
reversal candle but it cannot be used
only by itself it needs to be associated
with at least one more indicator so
either for example a strong volume so
here first thing the volume is low so
this gives less power to the scandal
first thing
uh second thing it needs to be confirmed
by the next scandal or by a short-term
breakout so here we are below the moving
averages so that's not very good we
don't have any short-term breakout we
don't have a high volume so we have this
reversal candle but let's be honest it's
not very powerful so
let's see if
on friday because today's it's is
thanksgiving uh if on friday
and the market is closed we manage to
close above those moving averages and
have a nice green candle like here
you see candle like that this would be a
very powerful reversal signal at that
time and it would probably mean that
this time we're gonna break out 44. so
let's see i don't know if we're gonna
have the scandal it's a 50 50 situation
here we're even slightly bearish on the
short term guys i'm here to tell you
what i really think this is not looking
perfect but we have this nice hammer
let's check on the first time frame
where are the short term resistance so
you can see here the same hammer is
appearing here it's not as perfect as on
the daily timeframe but it's still a
hammer but it has not been confirmed by
the next candles and we're looking for a
short-term breakout okay so to find a
breakout you just connect the highs that
you see and try to find a trendline that
is fitting well okay here i don't have
any let's be honest the maybe around 41.
so you see you need
the best i can do is to connect the two
highs that i had recently and it gives
me a level so let's say in a few hours
it's going to be around 41 all right so
if i get back on the daily time frame
guys
and it is
where we have those so the 20 period
moving average is at 40 so if we manage
to close above that basically i like to
be above those two 20 and 50 day moving
simple moving averages they are very
helpful to know the trend so of course
when there is no trend the market is
ranging you can see we have many
crossovers but whenever you are above
the two of them it's
usually great for the coming days for
now we are below the two of them that's
why i want to trade back above that and
it would it would look better another
thing that we want to see guys is some
nice consolidation period for now we are
consolidating true but we are not able
to stay with a low volatility we are not
able to stay with low volatility for a
long period you can see we have those
strong ups and downs which makes
actually this area still volatile and we
want to see this end of triangle to be
smoother just like we had here to know
that you can use the bully job and i'm
using them more and more because it's
actually i used to do that exercise of
finding the consolidation visually but
you can actually have this information
right away by looking at the bollinger
bands so you can see that here for
example after spending 10 days roughly
at the same level they were tightening a
lot and then we had this move so of
course it was not enough but it still
was a nice setup and you can see before
the real move up you look how tight they
were so we can compare
this so here this it was a bit the same
situation guys triangle we had one two
three four five six seven eight
nine days basically when the market was
not moving so maybe this is what is
gonna happen i don't know maybe it's
gonna be more brutal what i'm just
saying is that if we have those 10 days
when the market is just steady this
would be very good for the bullish case
we would of course need to have the
breakout on the upside to confirm the
new trend starting but it would be a
very nice setup that a lot of traders
would be looking at and this is what we
want we want many traders to be looking
at amc and get into this trade for the
breakout to happen and once the breakout
happens so
this would be very good guys so i'm
still very bullish here i still believe
we're gonna have a massive fifth wave
the reason behind is the unlimited flow
of money that is in the market guys and
you know this meme movement that started
with gme and then amc is so strong i can
feel it you know you know i'm doing
those daily updates i'm not maybe daily
but i'm doing those updates and i can
see the comments i can see everything
around that and i can especially see
guys
the synthetic short and the option
market that is just absolutely crazy so
stay with me guys i know that some of
you don't
want to look at that but you need to
look at that i'm going to make it very
simple we just want to see how many
options we have on the 145 strike bam we
were at 20.4 million last time i checked
which was two days ago right
so we want to see this number growing
because this is what is gonna make it
very hard for option market makers to
hedge the positions basically they're
going to need to buy a lot of shares on
the upside so what is it now 20.8
million guys so it's growing by a half a
million every three days roughly so
let's see where we are next week when
i'm gonna be back to france but
i'm pretty sure we're gonna be above 21
million shares
uh most of them are coming from gen 22.
i've already shown you that
let's check it again gently to 300 000
equivalent
shares so this needs to be multiplied by
100 but whatever
so 33 million equivalent shares on the
gen 22 maturity so it's by far the
biggest one i mean deck is big as well
december is big as well december is very
big as well okay we have a lot of
options as well on december so i'm gonna
be very paying a lot of attention to
what is happening with this number of
options if we get close to expiry are
they going to get rolled or not so right
now we have 70 000 on december 120 000
on jan if in december we didn't reach
145
and
i see this is coming here and that here
we have 200 000 options guys this would
be very very bullish this would be a
very good sign
that i'm gonna be paying attention to
and that i would let you know
so what else can we say dtc at 3.3 total
show 25 percent it's getting hot in here
bam i'm gonna move it here
let's compare quickly with what we had
in the past few months so
not moving for the past month okay this
year round three 3.5 not moving a lot
the maximum synthetic shorts around 20
so not any strong move in terms of
synthetic shorts but the 145 strike is
growing and this is a good indicator of
the bullishness that we have in this
market so that's it for today i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show see you guys